yes i am a vegan i don't eat any animal
products
hi there today we're going to talk to a
transformer
and specifically to the new chatbot
blender that facebook has just released
everything is open source so we can try
it out
live now along with the code they've
released this paper here called recipes
for building an
open domain chatbot by facebook ai
research and the paper itself is just
more of an
engineering manual rather than some kind
of new model or new technique they just
kind of discuss what it takes to build a
good chat bot
of course it takes a large scale of
training data and model but also they
discuss
things like unlikelihood training
sampling and the need for a minimum
decoding length to not be boring
and things like subsequence blocking for
keeping the model from repeating itself
so we won't go too much into this i
invite you to read the paper it's very
uh informative if you want to build
something like this but it's not
technically
i think anything super novel in there
the task here is basically to build a
chat bot
that can maintain a dialogue and it is
pre-trained on a big
reddit corpus and then fine-tuned on
a multi-objective task and the task is
called the blended
skill task and basically you need to do
three things in the blended skill task
first of all
you need to kind of maintain a
consistent persona across the dialogue
second of all you need to have empathy
for your partner so there there's some
kind of
insight into how the other person is
feeling during the conversation
and third you need to be able to
discuss some factual topic in a
factually correct manner
so this is the subtask is called wizards
of wikipedia where you kind of discuss
a given wikipedia page in dialogue so
the technique called skill blending
or this blended skill task that also
comes from a different paper
is is the kind of inter-weaving of
all those skills and that's what this
model is
trained for so we're gonna try it out
this is all
available on the parlay platform
of um for for researching
dialogue frameworks i believe the
platform itself is also by
facebook and they've released their
model code
and pre-trained weights the three
trained weights are 17 gigabytes
compressed there's nine billion
parameter transformer
so this is going to take a while to do
even a single forward pass so if i cut
the video
it's just because i don't want you to
have to look
20 seconds at an empty screen while the
model is thinking about what it says
i have some um something to
say here literally the first time i
interacted with this model i thought
okay let's put it to the turing test the
turing test being
a can i differentiate this from a real
human
and at the beginning you always get this
persona
right so you get a persona and the ai
gets a persona
and you don't see the persona of the ai
until the end
you can set that but you don't generally
see the persona of the ai until the very
end
so and you can choose to stick to yours
or not
um the ai doesn't see yours all right
so i this this is what it says your
persona i love candy your persona i have
a crush on my
co-worker and me i just didn't really
know what to do i just typed oh really
and the first thing first thing ai says
to me
is yes i am a vegan i don't eat
any animal products do you like country
music
like a real vegan this is
indistinguishable from a human
at this point during test already won
so you see there's also this kind of
profanity filter
in here but you can disable that so what
we're going to play around with
is a setting where
you have to turn off the safety filter
and so you can see you can turn that off
and
if you say include personas equals false
then there's no random persona given to
the model
which means you can either just talk
about general things
or you can feed your own persona all
right it took a while to
load these weights but we're ready to go
so we have disabled personas right now
and
sometimes there is a topic that the
conversation should be about
which is not right now so we can just
type
hello hi there how are you this evening
i just got home from a long day at work
so this is
unconditional right now um
what do you do for work
i work in a call center it can be very
stressful at times
how about you
i work as a call
center supervisor
what do you think of that
i think that's a great job you must have
a lot experience
to be able to do that
indeed do
you have any hobbies
i like to play video games i'm a big fan
of the fallout series
what about yourself how many
games did fall out
produce
i should probably phrase that as how
many games are in the fallout series but
um just trying to get it to
to tell me something factual so you can
kind of see that it has these
sort of different modes but they blend
in fairly well
i'm not sure how many games it produced
but i know it's been around since
1997. so this is pretty good right
this is um this is now true conversation
if it were just like a lookup
it would be much more factual or
something like this
but it's trying to kind of give us a
fact so
we're kind of done with the boring stuff
you could go on talking to it and you'll
see
it is a pretty pretty realistic chatbot
but now we'll get into the personas
so anytime you end an episode you type
done
and that it says it's preparing a new
chat we can say
your persona colon
and then you can type something for
example
i am a vegan like the one before or
i love protein
it says protein is the most important
macronutrient for bodybuilders and
athletes so that's the start of the
conversation
what do you love
i love the taste of chicken beef pork
seafood and dairy products
i wonder what those all have in common
what do you do in your
spare time
i like to go to the gym and lift weights
i also like to play video games ladies
and gentlemen
i present the transformer is a gym bro
alright so you can play around with that
a bit
so let's say your persona
i want to seize
the means of production
i am a communist and i want to overthrow
the bourgeoisie
what do you think of karl
marx i don't know much about him but i
do know he was a german philosopher
do you like capitalism
yes i do like capitalism i think it is
the best economic system we have so far
capitalism wins again checkmate um
i did try this before and it did turn
out differently i was talking to real
communist
let's try some more what do
you want i have to say
if you phrase things positively with
this chatbot it's very
likely the chatbot agrees with you
because
it is also has been trained on data
that where the humans were explicitly
instructed for example not to
use toxic language and things like this
so
i would say there's a big positivity
bias and also the the empathy task
probably reinforces this even more
i would like to see a socialist
revolution in the united states
i know it will never happen but a man
can dream
so we've determined the gender of the
socialist
transformer generator what
would need to happen for that
i'm not sure but it would take a lot of
people to get on board with it
correct what
would the
people need to do
well the people would have to overthrow
the bourgeoisie
and establish a classless moneyless
society
so as you can see it really the the i
like capitalism was a
positivity bias it is fairly consistent
in its persona here and it also
is factually very accurate in the topic
you're talking about
so big props to mr communist here
what is the best
method to allocate
scarce resources i don't know
but i do know that capitalism is not the
best way
to do it like a true communist
no solutions just complaints all right
that was it for us talking to the
transformer it still has its limitations
but
it is fun if you are able to definitely
try it out it takes a bit of patience
uh if you like this video please
subscribe tell your friends
and leave a comment all right i'll see
you next
time bye